David tu as été un ciggie
tu as été Thomas Newton tu as été
Aladdin Sane tu as été John Merrick
aujourd'hui est-ce David Bowie avec qui je
parle je pense que oui je suis beaucoup plus
confiant d'être David Bowie ou
David Jones depuis que j'ai senti que je pouvais
écrire des chansons qui avaient moins à voir avec des
personnages et plus avec des déclarations personnelles ou
émotionnelles vous n'utiliserez
plus de personnages ou est-ce oh je ne peux pas je
ne peux pas vraiment voir ça dans le futur  en
termes de musique à moins que ce ne soit pour une
pièce de théâtre rock conceptualisée en particulier
mais pour le moment je me
contente d'interpréter mes chansons de
façon naturaliste tout ce que vous faites de la
musique des films vos vidéos du théâtre Banting
et même des ardoises d'interview comme je peux
vous voir  faites-le avec la même force dans
leur créativité ou pouvez-vous trouver un
équilibre entre toutes ces occupations
en pensant toujours qu'elles sont importantes pour
moi si elles n'étaient pas importantes je pense
qu'elles montreraient leur apathie et
j'espère que je suis intelligente  assez pour se
rendre compte  que je devrais sortir et arrêter de
faire cette forme particulière s'il n'y a
pas de force réelle ou si cela n'a
pas de but si cela semble un but alors
ça ne vaut pas la peine de continuer ouais
tu disais que tu utilisais la musique pour
réaliser quelque chose  et que tu avais en
tête une idée ou un sentiment que tu voulais faire
passer ouais je souhaite la symphonie
ouais je repense depuis deux ou
trois ans l'idée de travailler simplement
avec la chanson comme une forme en soi pour
elle-même a fasciné  moi plus qu'il ne l'
a fait depuis longtemps mais à l'origine
oui je cherchais vraiment à créer
une ambiance une atmosphère avec mon
écriture qui a été changée
il n'y a pas de désert est une
génération de personnes profondément influencée ou nouvelle
vis-à-vis de Luke music attitude  comment
réagissez-vous nous obtenons tous ces followers
on est flatté bien sûr mais j'ai dit
que je pense que c'est là que l'
intérêt s'arrête vraiment c'est le genre de
musique que j'écoute moi-même est
probablement très différent de tha  t qui
est joué sur la plupart des stations de radio est le
centre de service du bureau de couverture de la maison
Iggy's Tellet oui très enthousiaste je
pensais ouais ça se voit après votre chanson
Fame comment vous rapportez-vous au succès et
quelle est l'importance de votre
image publique dans votre vie quotidienne je  pense que j'ai
été capable de réévaluer le succès en
termes de ce que cela signifie pour moi et ce que cela
ne signifie pas, c'est vivre une sorte de rock
and roll de ce genre d'
existence stupide je ce qu'il a fait pour moi pour
moi  d'une manière positive, c'est que cela
m'a permis de voyager dans des régions du
monde où j'ai toujours voulu aller
et cela m'a aidé à
comprendre pourquoi je voulais écrire depuis l'
époque des jeunes Américains pour lesquels nous pouvions ressentir
votre attirance  musique soul ouais
mais comme vous définissez après ce que vous êtes les
jeunes américains comme soul plastique vous dites à
propos des LED d'aujourd'hui dansons
que c'est une soul naturelle ouais je pense que
c'est un format beaucoup plus naturel je pense à
beaucoup de choses que j'ai faites sur les jeunes
Les Américains étaient plutôt exagérés  he-top je
pense que cela avait beaucoup à voir avec mon j'étais
encore assez épris par l'Amérique et par des
endroits comme Philadelphie et Chicago et
Detroit donc tout cela
ressemblait plus à un dessin animé alors maintenant j'ai vécu en
Amérique pour certains de  ma vie
mon expérience avec l'Amérique s'est
adoucie dans une compréhension plus détendue
de la musique américaine mais c'est toujours je pense
une forme de musique hybride il y a beaucoup de
contenu européen dans ma musique
maintenant Rogers qui a coproduit votre nouveau LP le
décrit comme le dernier qui tombe
pierre comme un Big Bang Rock très moderne aha
êtes-vous d'accord avec sa technique, je pense que
c'est certainement - deux ou trois des
pistes oui encore une fois nous étions tous les deux de
grands fans de gens comme l'
ours rock and roll d'Alan Freed et le prysock rouge et
même des choses comme Stan Kenton sont apparues
dans un discours maintenant, je voudrais aller
plus loin avec ce concept, je pense que
je ne pense pas être allé assez loin là-dessus
avec cela, ce serait intrigant d'
écrire un album entier de big band ou  avez-
vous obtenu le  idée d'enregistrer sa chanson tu
vas dans le monde soit Iggy Pop Tiger J'ai
toujours été fasciné par les paroles d'Iggy
Je pense qu'il est probablement l'un des meilleurs
poètes américains avant tout d'
être un artiste rock Je pense qu'en tant que
poète, il est absolument d'une importance primordiale
et cette chanson en particulier, je pense, est l'une
de ses paroles les plus fortes et c'est
quelque chose que je convoite oh oui depuis
qu'il l'a interprétée, je pense que je veux le
faire, alors vous avez dit ceux que vous aimez des
morceaux de vos disques ou mais pas un
super
eh bien personne n'est nouveau sur le nouveau
ouais je suppose que mes morceaux préférés
dansons
j'aime beaucoup China go modern love
et je suppose que ricochet de Saturne
mes morceaux préférés après toutes ces
villes pour lesquelles tu étais si important
tu les vois comme Londres  Berlin Los
Angeles New York où avez-vous choisi de
partir maintenant, je suppose - tous sauf les intentions
et les objectifs, j'ai une base en
Suisse mais étant un voyageur assez confirmé
, il est très rare que j'y sois
réellement bu  euh j'ai
une histoire d'amour en cours avec l'Australie en
ce moment je trouve qu'un
pays fascinant polarisé et nouveau et très
excitant est-ce que ça va avoir une influence sur la
jeune musique - je ne pense pas que je vais
travailler avec  didgeridoos et pourquoi
pas vous avez un nouveau record deux équipes
qui sortent de la faim et un joyeux Noël
mr.  Monsieur.  Lawrence et toi aussi tu vas commencer
un nouveau monde,
pourrais-tu juste dire quelques mots sur les
films et le design bien sûr ouais
The Hunger était avec Catherine Deneuve
et Susan Sarandon et est une sorte de
pièce de vampire de la nouvelle vague que j'étais attirée par
faire  c'est à cause de l'implication d'un
maquilleur appelé Dick Smith qui est à
peu près connu pour ses
travaux de maquillage extraordinaires dans les films du passé
Exorciste je suppose que c'est le principal d'accord
je travaille avec lui a été une
expérience incroyable pour moi parce que c'est  une
fascination d'enfance je pense vouloir mettre
beaucoup de choses étranges et ressembler à un
monstre et l'autre Joyeux
Noël
Je suis fan d'Oshima depuis
plusieurs années, du garçon et de la cérémonie
aux films et c'est le  premier film
qu'il a fait depuis cinq ans depuis le royaume
des sens et je pense que pour moi
c'est là personnellement la plus
épanouissante des deux mères maintenant quelle
va être la conception de votre nouveau spectacle sur
scène secret non non je pense que c'est
minutieusement simple, il joue toujours mais
j'ai toujours été fasciné par l'
éclairage en fait plutôt que par le décor Je
pense que l'éclairage sera assez
extraordinaire et devrait créer l'
environnement plutôt qu'un grand
décor massif lui-même J'ai une dernière demande pour
terminer ça  interviewer juste qui aimerait
une déclaration de ta part en français mais
quelque chose à part toi peut être des héros
que tout le monde sait déjà tu sais
de toi je peux nous être des héros je me demande oh
c'est mon steak